I Am Legend is about a zombie-like horde wiping
out much of humanity, but its confusing ending
and butterfly symbolism become a lot more
clear if you understand the personal journey
of its hero.
Created by genetically altering measles, the
Krippin Virus seemed like a "miracle cure."
Unfortunately, after its initial promise,
the virus mutates with catastrophic results.
The virus kills 5.4 billion people, with 5%
transformed into zombie- or vampire-like "Darkseekers."
One percent of the population remains immune,
which includes Neville, a virologist for the
U.S. Army played by Will Smith.
Neville remains in New York City after it
is placed in military quarantine.
Although Neville is nearly entirely alone
in New York, he's still got his faithful dog
Sam for company.
Although Neville's world-saving quest to create
an antidote gives him long-term purpose, his
nurturing and caring for Sam gives him a reason
to continue in a daily basis.
Sam provides immediate meaning.
A series of flashbacks slowly reveal events
before the quarantine, contextualizing Neville's
mindset.
These flashbacks depict the critical moment
Neville evacuates his wife Zoe and daughter
Marley.
Then tragedy strikes when another helicopter
collides with Zoe and Marley's helicopter,
killing them.
Shortly before her death, Neville had promised
Marley that he would make the monsters go
away.
It becomes clear from that point that present-day
Neville is seeking personal salvation in finding
the cure; not only for the future of humanity,
but so his family's death won't be in vain.
The death of Zoe and Marley also explains
Sam's value.
"Sam, you protect daddy, okay?"
"No, I can't take a dog."
From that moment on, Sam becomes a living
remnant of Neville's old life, the only family
member he can love and care for.
Bob Marley's song "3 little birds" is intertwined
with the theme of I Am Legend.
The song stands for belief in a brighter future
and inspires Neville in times of need.
It also facilitates a form of cathartic escapism
that guards Neville from insanity.
His daughter was named after the cultural
icon, implying that long before the end-of-world
events, the original Marley was an inspiration
for Neville.
A conversation at one point with fellow survivor
Anna near the end of the film even suggests
that Neville chose his career as a virologist
thanks to Marley.
While talking to Anna, Neville says:
"He had this idea—it was kinda a virologists
idea—he believed that you could cure racism
and hate, literally cure it, by injecting
music and love into people's lives."
In an act of revenge for trapping a Darkseeker
for his tests, Neville falls into a trap and
is ambushed by other Darkseekers, including
canines also infected with the virus.
After escaping to the safety of his home,
Neville realizes his dog Sam is infected.
Unlike her owner, Sam isn't immune from the
virus.
In a scene that would melt the coldest of
hearts, Neville is forced to strangle his
best friend and only companion.
Sam's death alone doesn't break Neville—it's
everything her death represents.
She's the tie to his past life, a daily reminder
of his motivation to find redemption, and
a buffer between being alone and experiencing
suffocating loneliness.
Rationality is replaced by rage when Neville
embarks on a suicidal act of revenge.
Just as Neville is about to become an evening
snack, a beam of light scares the Darkseekers
away.
After three years with no response to his
radio broadcast, another face of humanity
has finally arrived.
However, rather than express gratitude for
saving him, Neville is dismissive and struggles
to communicate.
"Every single person that you or I has ever
known is dead!"
As I Am Legend reaches its climax, the situation
becomes desperate when a large group of Darkseekers
invade Neville's home.
Neville, Anna, and Ethan flee to the basement
laboratory for safety.
There they discover that Neville's antidote
is finally working.
The Darkseekers make their way to the lab,
with one taking lead and smashing himself
into the glass partition.
When the leader smashes himself into the glass,
the cracks resemble a butterfly.
Taking notice of the butterfly tattoo on Anna's
neck, Neville has a realization that this
might indeed be divine intervention.
This connects to a gesture from Neville's
daughter Marley earlier in the film:
"Mommy, look it's a butterfly."
"Marley, enough!"
Neville understands this is no coincidence.
After a moment of realization, Neville takes
action.
He draws blood containing the cure from the
Darkseeker test subject and gives it to Anna
and her son.
After seeing that his efforts to make a cure
weren't in vain, Neville is now comfortable
paying the ultimate hero's sacrifice to save
Anna and Ethan.
After Neville's selfless final act, Anna and
Ethan make it to the colony and hand over
the vial containing the cure.
Neville has become the titular legend.
In the alternate ending of I Am Legend, the
themes of the story are drastically changed.
The Darkseeker alpha wipes his own blood onto
the glass in the shape of a butterfly.
Neville then turns to the Darkseeker test
subject on his table, the one he's cured,
and notices a butterfly tattoo on her neck.
Neville takes a leap of faith and opens the
glass partition, risking his life to reunite
the Darkseekers.
Once Neville's awakened the female, the two
Darkseekers embrace in a moment of surprising
humanity.
Smith's character realizes that the mutants
are able to express love and are closer to
humanity than he realized.
From the Darkseekers' perspective, Neville
preyed on them, kidnapping and experimenting
on their friends, family, and loved ones.
He's a legend, but for the wrong reasons—in
line with the original book, he has become
the monstrous legend of a new world.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.